who's Taft Oh like oh the President Taft  Taft Taft who's fat right  Yosemite Sam how dr. robotnik hands out  Yosemite Sam absolutely  oh that's tough the Selleck had the  staff I go smell like that once  Tom Selleck I'm gonna say Tom Selleck  Tom Selleck  but only because everyone used to say my  dad look like Tom still haven't had a  moustache monopoly guy monopoly guy  neither make cartoons come on  Daniel day-lewis  stop right there fingers kind of done  Genghis Khan oh man Jesus doesn't boy my  favorite celebrity mustache I like the  James Harden I feel like I would be able  to rock that because I'm one of those  people who looks a lot better when his  face is obscured so I would like as much  great as possible did have to be living  ulysses s grant i i'd like you know like  early Springsteen I think like young  Springsteen that dude knew what he was  doing